you ready let's do it
you'll kill
oh Stephen congratulations you're both
one step closer to the title of forged
and fire champion and a check for 10
grand all that you need to do now is go
home and recreate an iconic weapon from
history that weapon is
zombie nulu
good luck blade Smiths we'll see you in
five days
I want to get going my shop is I often
refer to as a hobbit hole
this is a fire breathing spider that
will eat you alive I make weird stuff
and this is really weird that doesn't
Lop off the head I don't know what will
this blade is a really difficult one to
shave because there's a lot of curvature
to get a blade like this to balance I've
got to do a lot of hammer work and I've
got to be really careful not to cancel
out everything I do on each Hammer strip
my competition is Steven who's a great
young Smith he doesn't have the kind of
experience that I do but none of us have
any experience making a nambe nulu so
it's going to be a tough race I'm
deciding to use a leaf spring the
nagambe use Salvage materials that
already had holes or shapes cut in it
and form their pieces around them I'm
going to drop a drift right down that
hole and just see if I can get the hole
to open up
I'm going to try to achieve good balance
with this blade it's a really unusual
shape so that it feels good in the hand
and that it will swing nicely
now I'm feeling the pressure because I
know that I have a lot to do today
propane I need to heat this sucker up
time to heat treat
this is a really critical point in this
process there's a lot that could go
wrong if the Blade's gonna fail I will
know very quickly after it's hard
there is a Warp
it's in the main section of the blade
if I try to straighten it and it cracks
I'm in trouble oh
today I'm gonna have to pee treat I
pretty much have to widen the whole top
I hate to take the time to carve up my
heat treat furnace but I really don't
have any other options at this point
I'm feeling pretty nervous right now
there's a lot that could go wrong I
could get a really bad warp or the blade
could fail to harden and I'd have to
start the process over again
man I hope that that's not like an omen
right there
oh hell I'm gonna go for it that's good
it doesn't look any worse than it did
when I put it in
that is such a huge relief
today is the day that everything has to
be done yesterday I was able to get all
of the warp out and The Temper that was
a relief
I am putting the handle on right now I
need to make sure that I don't settle
for gaps in misalignment I highly doubt
I'll hit the marks that all will hit
just because he has so much more
experience with finish and so the stakes
are much higher so this epoxy works very
fast and I'm becoming very aware of the
closing window of time I have here to
get everything assembled
oh I cracked the last piece in the
handle
mistake has been made there's no going
back I have just enough African
Blackwood to replace my last piece of my
handle at this point time is really
precious
when I make knives I try and pay
attention to the small details I'll take
the nickname Captain meticulous
the first thing I'm getting at this
morning are the globes that are required
element on the end of the handle the
Globes could be thought of as a really
large pommel they're using wood instead
of metal as a counterweight that'll make
it really accurate to the agambe nulu
got scales cut I made a weighted pommel
nut to put on to the very end so that I
can dial in the balance I'm adding a
leather spacer which will act like a
cushion this will all dampen vibration
like a shock absorber The Last Detail is
doing a leather handle wrap it's going
to be a great grip
so this is a one inch thick vanilla rope
a standard test for a lot of knife edge
stuff the worst case scenario would be
to find out that my Edge doesn't hold up
to about like that something like that
could send me home and here we go
and that is a pass
bladesmiths welcome back to the forge
I've had five days at your home for just
work on your finale weapons you know
what's next the weapons test Dave
gentlemen this is the sharpness test to
test the sharpness of your blades I'll
be cutting into our cane man here
Paul you ready yes I feel good I know
that the geometry behind my Edge is thin
and convex so it should cut through the
cane very well
[Music]
this is what I love to see come back in
the third round this feels like a weapon
It Cuts Like a weapon it went right
through that cane you nailed it thank
you all right Stephen you ready for this
yes sir Dave is clearly excited about
Paul's blade which is great for Paul I'm
a little worried because I want to be
excited on my blade too but we'll see
foreign
your weapon same weapon different feel
it's a different weight it's a different
balance but the cuts you can see it just
passed right through there wasn't any
resistance on that cane nicely done
that felt really good to hear never
expected to make it this far based on
how round one went
and it just feels good to have made
something that's effective
gentlemen the test the strength and
durability of your blades I'm going to
chop into these clay pots this is not
about what your blades do to the pots
but these pots can do to your blades
Paul you're up first
hitting something as hard as a clay pot
I don't have any idea what it's going to
do to my Edge
the balance is really nice on this it's
heavy where it needs to be heavy when
you're swinging it you know where it's
going right there's a slight roll on the
edge of your blade right here that I can
get a fingernail on that
everything down at the handle and the
guard are still tight yeah other than
that one roll seems to have held up well
all right Steve it's your turn you ready
for this yes sir okay
nice and straight I don't really see
anything out of alignment your Blade's a
little bit heavier than Paul's but it's
got a good feel it's got a good balance
the wood you've gotten the handle and
the extension of this handle is put the
balance in a really nice place cool yeah
I can't feel any deformation on the edge
well done thank you
next up The Kill test Doug
I know what the weapon was used for and
I'm starting to wonder pretty hardcore
what we're about to do to these dummies
bladesmiths this is the kill test the
number noodle wasn't just a weapon used
by tribal Chief to show status it was
also known as the beheading sword of the
Congo so to see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do I will take
your number doodle I'll deliver lethal
slashes on this ballistics dummy
foreign
it feels good in the hand it's got a
racist edge here that upon its initial
delivery into the gut that dug in deep
all the way into the bowel now for its
intended purpose of going up to
decapitate the head well come on it's
got no head it's dead
your weapon
it'll kill thank you all right Stephen
it's your turn you ready yes sir
[Music]
all right Stephen your blade is sharp it
lacerated all the way into the bowels
but you can see that cuts through the
jaw and all the whistles ahead
the wood that you have here it's smooth
but it's the indexing that you have for
that the way you have it flattened out
and avoid that feels good in the hand
yes sir and it will kill thanks
oh Stephen the judge's deliberation is
complete the forged and fire Champion is
Stephen congratulations you are the
forge and fire Champion Paul thank you
very much for turning in such a
beautiful weapon but now I have to ask
you to surrender it and please leave the
forge
I certainly accept the judge's decision
first thing I'm going to do when I get
home is clean my shop and get on with
what I usually make
Stephen congratulations you are the
forged fire champion and we'll be
receiving a check for 10 grand how do
you feel I feel great it's a little
surreal I damn well approved what I came
here to prove I am creative and that I
can make a functional weapon and not to
be the most experienced if you put your
heart into stuff that things you know
can turn out well as fun as hell and I'm
glad that I came out on top
foreign
fire final
so far we've asked you to design and
produce a weapon of your own choosing
to claim the forged and fire Crown you
must design and Forge our mystery weapon
one of the most famous and revered
weapons from history
the Japanese katana
the katana is the traditional weapon of
the Samurai the noble class of Warriors
and feudal Japan since around 800 A.D
the katana was formed from hundreds of
thin layers of the purest steel
available the quicker draw of the sword
was well suited to combat where life
versus death depended on the weapon you
carried into battle over the centuries
the katana has taken on many mythical
properties in Legend and culture from an
ability to slice through other swords to
splitting a hair and it is the sort of
choice for characters in mega hits like
Kill Bill and The Walking Dead good luck
gentlemen we'll see you in five days
my name is Rich Greenwood by day I work
on swimming pools and at night I'm a
bladesmith I am absolutely amazed that I
made it this far at every stage of the
competition I thought this is it I'm
going home with five days I think I can
actually prove my worth
I've got no power hammers no presses
everything is by hand my goal is to get
the blade to where I can quench it so
what I'm doing here is I'm breaking all
the sharp edges because you got any
sharp edges you got a lot better chance
of cracking something this is where it
all happens it'll kill me or it'll make
me here we go
probably
you
about four seconds into the quench I
heard a loud tick
I knew that was it it was all over
several cracks along the tip
it just got the blade way too hot before
I clenched it and uh when you've got too
hot a blade and you throw it in cooler
water tends to crack I'm not going to
say All Is Lost just yet I'm gonna bust
my ass and I'm gonna try and get
something made but I'm proud of them yet
this is my final shot to stay in the
competition this blade doesn't survive
high miles
getting ready
I'm quenching now
my name is Matthew Parkinson I've been a
blacksmith for 15 years
I'm gonna go for a full hardened blade
so strong and so fine-grained it should
outperform anything else that anybody
can put on the table that's ready for
heat treating
I'm gonna slide my blade down there
about 600 Degrees
I'm just gonna bring it up and let it
cool
I'm doing this for my son I'm doing this
so that he can be proud of me see what
Daddy's doing set in the store right now
nice I like this sword a lot
still a little apprehensive about what
the judges are going to be looking for
I'm just going to cut a couple water
bottles make sure the geometry is good
that was a successful test cut
this is a really good sword
to measure how your blades stand up
against flesh
Doug will cut through these fish Rich
yours is up let's put it to the test
nice
it will cut yes it will it felt good in
the slice good but the recovery was a
little heavier but it still felt like
it'll give me a close shave good job
okay Matt you're up next are you ready
yep
it doesn't cut and I'm a little confused
by that I don't know why it didn't cut
foreign
it's got a very good feel to it it's
very light it's got a very nice balance
to it and
now for the kill test in this we have a
ballistics dummy that pretty much
simulates the human form organs and
tissues the katana traditionally has a
razor-sharp edge that allows me to find
the gaps in between the armor I'm going
to try that with your blade to see how
well it does richer up first
[Music]
let's take a look at the damage
oh
the thrust and the slice went all the
way into the internal organs in here
and the kill shot went deep all the way
into the liver
think on the kill test
this will kill
okay map Europe
foreign
he's disemboweled here
a nice big puncture in here that
definitely will get the liver
I think it's past the kill test
you've both obviously brought deadly
Implements of War here but now
it's time to Lock and Load gentlemen
because for the strength test we're
leaving the forge we're heading to the
gun range
what
all right gentlemen this is the final
test for the forged and fire
championship
strength test
your weapons will be tested on their
ability to split a bullet your swords
are going to be locked into a vice then
we're gonna fire a bullet at your blade
all right Matt you ready break it
three two one engage
on that your sword split a bullet
there's no damage on the Edge at all
held up extremely well that is a real
true sign of your craftsmanship thank
you very well done all right Rich you're
up next when I look at him set the gun
up and get ready to shoot that blade
there's a little bit of doubt in the
back of my mind thinking it may not
survive this three two one engage
[Applause]
didn't even move
it splits the bullet I couldn't have
been happier there's no mark on the
blade at all held up perfectly no
chipping everything looks great thank
you
congratulations gentlemen you should be
proud of the work that you've done which
only makes the judge's decision that
much harder we'll see you back at the
forge
Matt rich
in just five days you have both forged
elegant and lethal Japanese katanas
but in this competition there can only
be one winner of ten thousand dollars
Matt
you are the forge to fire champion
congratulations
Rich you did not make the cut I wish you
had done a little bit more finished work
we let the handle get a little bit
skinny and it was almost the same
proportions on each side so I know you
ran into a time constraint but it did
split a bullet and that's truly
something to be proud of I feel a little
disappointed but the better bladesmith
wants
well Matt congratulations you are the
fortune fire Champion you're going to
claim a ten thousand dollar check how do
you feel this is awesome your blame is
beautiful not only is it beautiful but
it's fast got so cleanly through the
fish and on the ballistic dummies that
Justice involved It For The Kill test
great job lay it aside I was really
impressed with your handles set up
symmetrically it was correct we'd get
good control good grip on it very nicely
done this is such a rush I want to drive
home and kiss my son I'm the fortune
fire champion
Justin Nick congratulations you fellas
are in the final round of this
competition now we're sending you back
to your home for just to recreate this
iconic weapon from history
a pair of Frankish throwing axes
good luck we'll see you in four days
good luck now good luck to you man
it feels great to be back home
I have to make a pair of crankish
throwing axes
there's a lot of subtle curves to them
so it's gonna be a real challenge I'm
gonna take my piece of mild steel I'm
gonna Forge it out and then I'm gonna
fold it over on itself and then I'm
gonna fit it for a bit of high carbon
steel in the middle I think that might
work mild steel doesn't like to weld at
the heat so carbon steel does hopefully
she welds
so I'm really excited we've made it to
round three ready to get sweat and get
some Sparks throwing on this thing So
the plan today is I'm going to take some
1018 mild steel we're going to start by
drilling two holes go in with a drift
chisel it out start forming our eye on
both of these
it looks like a good eye right there
it's time to really profile this thing
so I'm taking it to the power of hammer
that way they move a whole lot easier
I have the profile forged out have the
eyes drifted feeling pretty good about
day one but we got a whole lot more work
to do
morning at day two and I'm pretty tired
yesterday I was able to get both my axes
or Dr welded together now I just got to
finish drawing them out today
I want to get that done to shape and it
looks like it's staying together oh
never mind it is not staying together I
got a massive seam where that Forge Road
is supposed to be
the boat didn't take at the very back of
this
so I'm gonna try to forge out this other
head and almost right away it's split
apart it's still good so don't like that
cheese tend to even really Forge welding
it again so I have to start over I don't
know what these tests are going to be
but they're always brutal so I need to
make them strong hopefully describe the
test
what I'm gonna do is take a piece of
this mild steel and I'm going to forge
it out to shape and then guide in the
squat for the high carbon bit I really
have to get a good weld here I can't
afford to solder over again
because day two the plan for today is to
really fix those eyes and really get
them to the shape I want
ended up stretching way too much
material one of the eyes ended up
cracking there's no saving these
and starting to panic I mean I don't
have a whole lot of room right there at
this point I'm burning daylight just
gonna have to scrap it and start over
I'm gonna do the wrap method basically
take a flat bar of Steel and wrap it
around an eye and have a carbon steel
core running all the way through instead
of just a bit
don't really feel good about it but I'm
gonna really power through and work as
fast and hard as possible
[Music]
my forged welding went good I believe
they're good enough for heat treat
I feel like the heat treat process went
really well so next two days I can focus
on fit and finish
[Music]
it's the morning of day three I still
got a little more forging to do still is
nice and hot give it a cup of whacks and
it's feeling good already I'm like 99
sure I have good forage weld
go straight into the oil
oh yeah
hard axes have to have a handle so I cut
out the hickory now it's time to shape
them
I can feel the sawdust adhering to my
cheeks
so it's the morning of day four today
I'm gonna play dress up these axes right
now that are assembled then I'm going to
do some finer detail work
[Music]
so they're both at the finish that I
want no I need to go above and beyond
that's what my mom would have wanted me
to do this was a challenge and I'm
really proud that I pulled it off
all right blade space well frankly your
Frankish throwing axes look fantastic
but are they lethal well to find that
out I will take your weapons and deliver
some well hellish of a blow on this
ballistics dummy
just hit me up first you ready let's put
it to the teeth
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
Justin every chop and slash is deep
overall sir it'll kill thank you
all right Nick it's your turn right
there fun let's do this
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
impact
crushes the face easily in the head your
edges they dig in with every chop and
slash it'll kill thanks though good job
late Smiths welcome to the strength test
I will be throwing you know Frankish
throwing axes into this large wall
Justin you're up first you ready for
this yeah let's do it
well Justin there is
a ding on this blade right here where my
finger is
your handles are comfortable the problem
I have with them this bulb is more
fitted for a fighting ax as retention a
throwing ax you kind of want to let it
go but in all your axis held up nice job
thank you
Nick you're up you ready for this let's
do this
foreign
your edges held up great I can't even
tell that they've been thrown handles
show no damage nice job
blade Smiths this is our sharpness test
the foot soldier attack
this is all about what the edges of your
weapon will do on the protective
clothing of this foot soldier just in
the up first you ready yeah kill it
right Justin your edges over here as you
can see on the clothing on this it cuts
right into this foot soldier overall sir
your weapons
it will cut go
all right make your turn sir you ready
play some good music
all right Nick no glinting or rolls
through your edges
sharp with every cut that went through
it'll cut thank you
all right blade Smiths you guys have
brought in some high quality competitive
and nicely matched Frankish throwing
axes but only one of you can be the
forged and fire champion
Nick congratulations you are the fortune
fire Champion Justin unfortunately your
Frankish throwing axes did not make the
cut Justin both sets of axes performed
well in all of our tests so this
basically came down to that small amount
of damage you took in the strength test
and the overall design of your axes yes
sir Justin you did a great job but at
this time I have to ask you to please
surrender your blades
I came here I did good I think I
represented myself well and I think if
nothing else these tests show that I can
make it work in Blade
Nick congratulations you're the forest
of fire champion and that's a title that
comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars good job man please present your
access to the judges
this experience was incredible I had so
much fun
I came here to win for my mom she was my
biggest fan and I've done exactly what I
plan to do
I didn't mom
that's why I'm Billy Bob congratulations
you made it to the final round of this
competition now we're sending you back
to your home forges for five days to
recreate an iconic weapon from history
and that weapon is
the wrong fire
originating as early as 400 BC the
rumphaya was a fearsome weapon
prominently used by thracian tribes of
Eastern Europe it featured a Long
single-edged Blade that had great
cutting and slashing strength due to the
Blade's slightly forward curve usually
forged with iron Warriors had to use two
hands to wield this heavy weapon using
an overhead sweeping or hacking motion
to attack from close distances first
mentioned in historical text by the
ancient Roman historian Titus livius it
was recorded as one of the key weapons
in violent thracian Warfare good luck
blade Smiths we'll see you in five days
foreign
Phelps and I was the first person from
Tennessee that I know of the past master
smith test what I love about Blake Smith
and 200 years from now somebody else is
going to be picking it up and looking at
it that really satisfies me it looks
pretty good
the thing I'm worried about is the
handle I went with a Full Tang which
makes it a little bit heavier I might
have to drill some holes in there and
take away some weight
[Applause]
that made me a little nervous
next we will play it get ready for heat
treat this will help keep part of the
metal soft and old parting it hard
I feel really nervous about quenching
something this long but what the heck
let's go see what happens
if this heat treat goes wrong I could be
in serious trouble the time it takes to
work out another sword this long I've
been down and out I'm more nervous than
a mouse that's running from a cat on
this
foreign
it looks perfect
check it out here
there's Dragon right there
kind of running out of time if I don't
get this blade ready to start Billy Bob
could take home the money I have got to
fix it
it's better if I had a lot more time I
could really Stone this Edge and get it
even sharper than that but I think it's
going to go through everything they put
up against it we just had to see
foreign
everybody in the knife World calls me
Billy Bob I've been at master smith for
eight years when I decided to make a
knife I'm just going to do it and
there's not a lot of planet to it you
just
keep doing it until it's nice
the sword isn't fitting all the way
through the forward so I just made one
renovation
I just knocked a hole in the firewall so
I think I'm going to make a simple
pattern of Twisted Damascus and I can
put it on the handle and give it a
little detail
oh never pick a snowball up in a
blackfill shop because it could be hot
I'm way behind me this is Noble the
handle it's as hard as I expected
today I'm gonna try to fit and shake the
handle
I'm doing it in two pieces it just adds
to the craftsmanship
[ __ ] the handle is looking a lot better
than I thought it would but we're never
Out of the Woods until we send this bad
boy off
the thread they're cooking being the
perfectionist I'm gonna keep messing
with it I'll get it right that may be
the downfall this whole thing
master blade spits to see what kind of
lethal damage your run fires will do
we'll take your own fires and deliver
lethal slashes and thrust on this wild
boar carcass Dwight you're up first you
ready I'm ready as you can see I'm still
recovering from an injury so to be my
arm today I'd like to welcome my brother
RJ markaida
foreign
on the initial draw cut it is sharp to
where it lacerated deep into this wild
boar carcass on the thrust it penetrated
easily into the carcass and on the final
cut right here your blade cut all the
way through the carcass overall you're
on fire to kill thank you good job all
right Billy Bob it's a hard night to
follow but let's do it
you can index better okay
all right Billy Bob it's so light you
can almost wield it with one hand The
Edge over here is so sharp it lacerates
easily without much force the profile
you have over here for thrusting allowed
it for a very deep quick and out
penetration
overall you're on fire will kill thank
you
next up is a strength test Ben
gentlemen to test the strength and
durability of your blades I'm going to
clamp them into this machine and it will
deliver a strike on the sugar cane of
about 500 pounds of force remember this
test is all about what the sugar cane
does to your blade and not what your
blade does to the sugar cane right I've
already clamped yours in are you ready
to go I'm ready three two one
that's right your blade held up
perfectly it's like it didn't hit
anything
it's still dead straight
very well done thank you Billy Bob
you're up next you ready I can't wait
all right let's do this three two one
ah
don't kill me
Oh Billy Bob I love the overall weight
it feels like it's a really good Chopper
and most importantly The Edge is still
as razor sharp as it was when you
brought it here
very well done thank you sir next up is
the sharpness test and for that I give
you today
all right gentlemen I'll be working my
way through this rope maze by cutting
we've seen your blades kill let's see if
they've held their Edge Dwight you're up
first you ready I'm ready all right
let's do this
foreign
your blade is just pristine I mean
there's there's not a Mark or a hair
hanging on it or anything feel wise it's
got a lot of forward weight it makes for
a very strong chop but I do have to stop
and slow it down and back it up I think
it's a beautiful weapon thank you thank
you
all right Billy Bob you ready to go
let's do it okay
[Music]
foreign
this is sharp it blew through rope like
nothing I felt I could really control
this weapon uh just because it it's so
much lighter up through here fabulous
weapon thank you well done
it's white Billy Bob both done masterful
work as expected from Master Schmitz
however in this Arena of competition
there can only be one forged and fire
champion and that champion is
Billy Bob congratulations you are the
forged and fire champion
thank you Dwight your blade was badass
but this time it didn't make the cut
Doug markaida will explain
Dwight first of all this is exactly what
we expect for a final round two
beautifully matched blades but your
blade is slightly heavy that offsets its
balance compared to Billy Bob's and it's
for that reason we're sending you home
Dwight I need to ask you to please
surrender your blade
no disgrace I believe both blades are
pretty equal I'd hate to have been a
judge being on forged and far is one of
the best experiences I've ever had if
it's something that you're passionate
about you need to go for it
Billy Bob congratulations you are the
new forest and fire champion and will be
receiving a check for ten thousand
dollars good job thank you I'm honored
that I'm here to do it please present
your weapon to the judges
the old man wasn't for some fire old man
come here and kicked ass and took names
it feels good now I'm proud of both of
us Dwight and I forged not only Blaze
but we forged a friendship I'm gonna go
home and take a break I'm gonna give me
a damn pedicure
you don't know what you're missing if
you ain't had one
well Nathan Gunner congratulations guys
you're moving forward in the third and
final round of this competition you made
your first blades out of guillotines and
we're going to continue on with the
darker side of History Theme by asking
you to build this blade four days
the Executioner sword
[Music]
the Executioner sword performed its
bloody work in 16th century Central
Europe unlike combat swords this lethal
blade features a straight double-edged
cutting blade with a blunt tip perfect
for swiftly chopping off the heads of
criminals this deadly weapon was used on
many aristocratic felons rather than the
ax since it allowed the victim to meet
his end in a dignified kneeling position
rather than face down with his head on
the Block while The Executioner's sword
fell out of use in the early 18th
century this gruesome sword is still
wielded in the 2019 video game Mortal
the voice was good luck we will see you
in four days
my name is Nathan Anderson from West
Valley Utah I'm a maintenance worker at
the Utah's Hogle Zoo I loved animals and
there's not too many places where I can
be welding and look up and see a giraffe
right there if I went Fortune fire the
ten thousand dollars is gonna go to
taking my wife on a trip to go looking
for bigfoot heat treat coming up just
don't want to rush it I don't want to
break it because that would be bad
all right
I don't think that anything went wrong I
feel pretty good about the quench should
be able to clean everything up and move
on forward from here so now it's time to
start working on the guard I've got my
finials right there hopefully those
won't add too much weight for what I
want to go for but I think I'm sitting
pretty good for right now there we go
I've got the guard fitting where I want
it to I need the handle comfortable so
that there's not a reason to be sent
home because it's going to get and then
we'll pin it
so I start engraving skulls and some
flames and things like that to kind of
make it my own pretty close
give it a test
this blade is so good I can smell
Bigfoot now
[Music]
my name is Gunner Wilbanks I'm a high
school football coach and teacher and
I'm part-time bladesmith my wife loves
it every time I make a knife I bring it
in to her both of my daughters and my
son they all have to hold it and it
turns out we all love Blaze
a few hours in and I'm almost halfway
there kind of forgot what it was like in
the little man's world just working with
a hammer because I don't have the power
tools I'm having trouble getting it
heated evenly because my storage is
short every time I slide my blade
through it's so long it wants to droop
on one end well every time that I'm
getting down here and getting the back
end of it hot the front end of it's
cooling off we gotta get the timing
right right here I get it in the quench
tank
I don't feel any Tings I don't feel any
cracks anything like that
that's not a sign you want to hear it's
soft on both ends that's not going to
work plan B is to go in for a second
Quench and instead of laying the blade
flat I'll lay it upright maybe I'll be
able to hold the heat a little bit
better that way and the blade's not
going to Sag on me if the quench doesn't
go well I go all the way back and start
at Ground Zero
thank you Jesus
thank you I'm elated that I'm actually
going to be able to use this blade it
seems to be going great
all right so far so good and hopefully
God willing and the creek don't rise
they might say you're the forge and fire
champion
it will kill you
basements welcome to the Keel test
the Executioner sword that word alone
just gives you visions of decapitated
heads so to find out what kind of lethal
damage your Executioner's sword can do
I'll deliver some while lethal blows on
this ballistics dummy
Nathan is it time it's time have fun
[Music]
crap
just a little off the top
[Laughter]
all right Ethan first stop this is a
heavy Beast it is so forward heavy that
you eat two hats to control that now
your handle construction is smooth I'll
give you that but it also feels a little
bit rounded over here where it actually
gives me much more control sideways than
it does this way but overall your
weapons sir filled with Keel awesome
all right Gunner your turrets are you
ready absolutely let's do this
[Music]
all right Gunners talk about your
executioner sword over here your blade
right here has a finer grind so it makes
it a little bit lighter and the edge
that you have here when it came to that
skull just glided into that overall sir
your execution your sword it'll kill
thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test the skull and bone chop
now to test the overall construction of
your blades as well as how they feel
while they're being used I'll be
chopping into these skulls and that
nasty giraffe bone
Nathan you're up are you ready yes sir
have fun
[Music]
holy draft
all right Nathan so right off man this
thing is heavy but once you get it
moving it's going but controlling it's
tough having said that your Edge hella
beautifully it's still just as sharp as
when I started which is pretty darn
sharp so good job on that thanks I like
sharp things
what if I said no
I'd say you don't watch this so much do
you exactly
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so gonna write off lighter
blade easier to control a lot of that
has to do with effect you've got more
handle here
now your blade it's got some compacting
on the edges but I wouldn't run my
finger down this Edge it's still pretty
sharp nicely done thank you sir
all right blades Vince this is the
sharpest test the Jackfruit and watery
jug slice
Ethan you're up first you ready yes sir
have fun all right let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
still Sharp
all right Nathan as far as the downward
chop it's a very clean cut easy no
resistance whatsoever now when I was
cutting as soon as I met the resistance
of the water it kind of rolled on my
hand
but anything that it did have contact
with it was able to cut overall sir your
weapon it will cut thank you
all right go under your turn so you
ready yes sir I am let's do this
foreign
[Music]
ER the handle construction you have here
is wide and avoid enough to where when I
hold on to it I can really tell where
the edge is and it's much easier to
control a blade like this in the slice
you can see that cuts nicely overall sir
your weapon it will cut thank you
foreign
fire champion and get that check for ten
thousand dollars now the judges
discussed your blades and they made a
final decision
today's Fortune fire Champion is
Gunner congratulations now Nathan you
fought hard man but unfortunately your
blade didn't make the cut I'm gonna have
to ask you to please step off the forge
floor thank you very much
congratulations
well I'm gonna have to find a different
way to take my wife to go see Bigfoot
but we're still gonna go
[Music]
well Gunner that makes you the forge of
fire Champion you just got yourself a
check for ten thousand dollars
congratulations thank you appreciate it
guys
[Applause]
I just won forged in fire feeling good
well I mean I've never thought I would
make it this far from day one I don't
necessarily think that I'm a better
Smith than any of these other guys that
just worked out in my favor today as far
as the money uh after football season
ends my wife and I will probably take a
long weekend somewhere
foreign
Chris Trenton congratulations you've
both made it to the final round and are
one step closer to ten thousand dollars
so far you've come to our Forge and
you've made a weapon of your choosing
now you're gonna head back to your home
Forge
and you're going to create a weapon of
our choosing
[Music]
and that mystery weapon is
[Music]
the chakra
the shock room is an Indian throwing
weapon which dates back hundreds of
years Warrior seeks would throw it like
a frisbee or spin it at high speeds on
their fingers before launching it into
the enemy the weapon of the Hindu god
Vishnu its exotic Nature has resulted in
it appearing in TV and movies odd jobs
lethal bowler hat in the James Bond
movie Goldfinger was a variation of the
weapon as was Xena's weapon of choice in
the cult TV series The indian warriors
would wear multiple shock rooms into
battle carrying them around their arms
their necks and even stacked high on
their heads in specially designed
turbines we will see you in five days
my name is Trenton ta I am not Trent who
is a blacksmith I am Trent the
blacksmith what I had to do is go to the
junkyard and find a very particular
piece for a jig a particular item to
allow you to very carefully control the
Contours of the item you're working on
in laying under some oak trees I find an
old oxygen tank
and so what we have now is our chakram
form
next I actually welded a stop just some
place to give me some leverage I'm going
to heat the bar and start bending it
around my jig so now I need to weld
these pieces together
[Music]
and there we go we have a hoop formed
this is going to be my base material for
my braided handle normally use it for
knife handles but I'm going to be using
this for the middle of our chakra
and there she is
the last thing that I'm going to do is
focus on making her pretty
this is going to be so Kick-Ass
[Music]
my name is Christopher Farrell being a
professional bladesmith you don't make a
lot of money winning this competition
will make the next year of operation
cost a lot easier to shoulder
anything in my shop to accommodate this
shape most people probably have a jig
set up so that they could pull this
around a lot easier I don't have a jig
so I've been doing a combination of
rounding it on the Horn of the Anvil and
using the bevel to help round it further
[Music]
pretty close I'm done with the initial
shaping
the only issues that I think I may run
into is Forge welding the seam of the
chakram because it might get burned
the heat is very inconsistent it's very
difficult to control precisely where
you're heating up in a charcoal Forge
you're kidding me right
you're burned got too hot somewhere else
not hot enough where the world needed to
happen so I'm going to cut out the
sections of the shock room that were
ruined and weld on a new section and
being a guy who works mostly with hand
tools I want to see if I can pull it off
it'll work out
or it won't
[Music]
well it ain't perfect but
foreign
for the strength test we're going to
take your chakromes and see if it was
designed well as a throwing weapon we're
going to use a specially designed
mechanical device that will launch your
weapon into the sugar canes because
sugar canes have similar consistency as
human limbs if your weapon can cut
cleanly through a sugar cane that would
indicate that you have a weapon that
would do mass destruction in the field
of battle
this device here is calibrated so that
every throw is going to be the same for
each of your designs Chris you're first
are you ready yes sir
foreign
engage
well Chris
it cut two sugar canes
I see no indentations on the edges here
this will cost maximum damage in the
battlefield
good job
okay thank you okay Trenton
you're up next
in three two one engage
I watch mine just kind of do an
overarching arc just a bloop
the sugar cane very low just a couple of
inches off the ground however it shears
them and that means I'm good well
Trenton because of the weight obviously
it doesn't fly out as high but it did
cut this definitely will be an ankle
cutter
Trenton's piece it's still cut-ish
now for the kill test
the chakram is primarily a throwing
weapon however in close quarter combat
sometimes throwing a weapon is not an
option Trenton you're up first this is
designed to be a handle correct yes sir
so in order to keep myself safe I'm
going to hold the handle and I have to
protect the back of my arm with this so
on the design alone that's a concern
let's find out what it does
[Music]
foreign
that performed quite well it cut some
ribs and it disemboweled the dummy
it will kill
good job Trenton Chris you're up next
excellent
[Music]
wow what really opened them up in the
belly here so he's totally disemboweled
definitely cut through all the way and
broke a rib
it'll kill
you have both performed outstandingly
however there can only be one winner of
ten thousand dollars
[Music]
Chris
you are the forged Empire Champion
congratulations
Trenton unfortunately your weapon did
not make the cut
ter has to be a light fast weapon so I
have some problems with the weight of
that weapon and once you added that
handle in the middle you left the realm
of chakram and went into the realm of
fantasy
and it kills me because I love looking
at it but when it came down to a shock
room that would work in combat it had to
go to Chris
trying to please surrender your weapon
of course I'm disappointed
fought real hard
thanks
I'm sorry
man Chris he did an awesome job that's
the kind of person you want to lose to
Chris congratulations you will receive a
check for ten thousand dollars
congratulations Chris and function and
form in historical accuracy your blade
performed the best I'm a little in shock
Chris isn't here anymore please leave a
message
foreign
you made it through to the final round
so far you've designed and presented a
weapon in your own styles
now we're going to send you back to your
home forges where you will make one of
the most iconic weapons from history
the Viking battle ax
the Viking battle ax was a brutal
killing weapon that played a significant
role throughout history Viking warriors
were mostly Farmers so when going off
the fight they would pick the tool they
had close at hand which was often a wood
cutting ax when later models took on
shapes more convenient to the Fighting
Man the battle ax was born the half was
made of wood and the curved head allowed
the ax to be used to hook an opponent's
ankle throwing him off balance and onto
the ground positioning the Viking to go
in for the kill with the large
razor-sharp Cutting Edge the battle ax
has a long and colorful association with
fantasy film and literature being the
weapon of choice for the dwarves and the
Lord of the Rings and The Hobbit as well
as for the players of fantasy computer
games such as World of Warcraft good
luck gentlemen
I'm Jonathan Porter and I am a farrier
the fancy word for a horseshoeer as well
as a full-time bladesmith I'm doing a
multiple layer patterned Steel battle ax
the Vikings they used a lot of
multi-layered Steel overall this will be
one sturdy ax
I am super pumped about this battle ax
the competition is definitely affecting
me I don't know why I don't just come in
here and Forge like I always do but this
contest sort of just messes me up man
I just wasn't paying attention I took my
eye off it and I and I cooked it it's
done
I gotta start over unbelievable
I forged another ax head and this time
the blade held together
I think the judges are going to be
impressed with the acts in general
we're buttoned up with a really nice
top-notch handle with leather wraps that
go along with the head that we've worked
so hard for
it's an end result that I think looks
good and I'm proud of so no matter what
they think I'm proud of what I'm going
to put in front of them this round
my name is Ryu Lim I was born and raised
in the Philippines I'm an iron worker
and I make blades for a living
the studio shop had everything man I got
the Bare Bones only the the basics
my Forge is basically a cast iron pot
with a hole drilled in the bottom where
I attached a black pipe and on that
black pipe I attached the hair dryer
using the hair dryer I introduced more
oxygen and the more oxygen you put it
the hotter it gets I'm gonna stretch out
the metal and I'm gonna wrap it around
the pipe to make an eye for the handle
I really have no peace because it's so
big it doesn't fit in my Forge I had to
make some adjustments to remedy that
when you're working with high-powered
power tools you gotta remember safety
first
of my protection
and respirator
the way it's going right now I'm not
getting enough Heat
I'm losing a lot of heat very quickly so
I might start over or make a new Forge
the first Forge wasn't working because
it was too small
so I added the Satellite Dish around it
so I'll be able to add more coal and
make a bigger fire
it's looking good right now I could move
on to the fun part
what is this it's forging next
we're Viking it the firefighters came
and unfortunately I was delayed an hour
your biggest thing we gotta deal with is
the package too close to the book I have
to move the forage and reposition
everything
hopefully it doesn't affect me too much
towards the end I don't have electric
sauce I'm gonna have to carve this down
I spent the last hour pounding in the
handle at the same time making it
it was tough but I'm just really curious
what the judges are going to say really
a battle ax doesn't have to be smooth
and shiny it just has to work it doesn't
have to be pretty to split skulls
the tessell leaf out of your ex I will
strike the side of beef here and see
what kind of damage it does
Jonathan you're up first I'm ready
your Edge held
it crushed to three bones
it will kill yes it will
for the next test I'm going to pass it
over to our European historical weapons
expert Dave
thanks Dave
Gentlemen The Viking ax was designed to
create the maximum amount of Carnage on
the battlefield
to test it in a chop test I'm going to
take five blows against this hardened
panel of Oak
now Oak was the common Building Material
of the time
and this was the preaching tool of the
time
right
thank you
I don't know if I can crawl through that
but seemed to do the job
that round handle though boy it wants to
twist in your hand
bit of an issue
and overall it felt pretty good
are you you're up next you ready
I'm ready let's do it
the hand is a little slippery so first
couple of tries it was slipping off I
had to make sure that it didn't go fly
off my hand
you cut about
three end into the fourth bone
this I believe
is a killer good job thank you very much
Dave
my ex may not be pretty
but it can definitely split some skulls
[Music]
well felt pretty good my hand could
travel on that handle whereas with that
leather wrap I couldn't really move my
hand while I was swinging
nice job thank you
well gentlemen your weapons have
performed well thus far but it's not
over yet we're gonna see just how much
punishment your weapons can take in our
strength test
Doug
for the strength test your access will
be placed on the specially designed
impact device the arm is set to deliver
maximum Force at the point of impact we
will deliver three strikes on the shield
that will give us a good indication of
how much pressure your ax can take
let's see if your weapon will survive
this test
Jonathan Let's test it three
two one engaging
engaging
engaging
I don't see any clear indentations on
your Edge a little indentation of The
Shield
your half seems to have held good job
thank you
for you you're next
three two one and get
and get
engaging
let's split the shield in half and all
the way through
Edge held
half is still secure
good job you have both done yourselves
proud as bladesmiths however in this
competition there can only be one winner
for you
you are the forged Empire Champion
congratulations
good job buddy good job man Jonathan
your weapon did not make the cut please
surrender your weapon
Lee I'm totally proud of the work that
I've done I mean I turned in a laminated
Viking battle ax so I'm not I'm not by
any means going home because I didn't do
enough in this case Ryu just did a
better job
feel very proud right now I work really
hard for this I guess it paid off it's
stress level got to you in the first
challenge you were able to pull it
together I mean you got a few issues but
you brought a true weapon you should
definitely be proud of thank you sir I
put my soul into forging that ax I gave
it everything I had and now I walk out
as a champion